i i feel like now that we're getting
ready to travel and now that it seems
like the country is slowly opening back
up i mean at the time of recording uh
japan have finally let in you know uh
work visas and student visas after like
what two years is it like two and a half
two years and who knows what the
situation is going to be like now when
this episode actually is released maybe
the country will be open and maybe a
bunch of you are going to be traveling
to japan for tourism and stuff like that
well the you know best case scenario is
that before the year ends people start
coming so hopefully this episode will
come in handy when you do eventually
come to japan yeah but uh
i mean so like probably gonna be a while
though yeah i don't know what's the time
to plan out you're right well yeah you
know like like many people pointed out
japan unfortunately uh has an extremely
older population
and older people don't really leave
japan and a lot of them have never left
japan never even gone out of the country
yeah so a lot of the people i think it's
like 80 or 70 percent of people agree
with the travel
ban right yeah whereas other countries
you know like europe uk it's like well
i've got to have a holiday in benidorm
oh my cousin's from who lives in
portland because people in uk want the
country to be open because otherwise
they'd be stuck in the uk
and where the [ __ ] is there to go on a
holiday in the uk butlins
yeah which is just why it sucks because
like obviously a lot of people from
america europe don't really understand
why japan isn't opening up and it's like
well you need to kind of understand the
yeah
well it's also because japan puts like
probably the most amount of effort into
their domestic tourism well i mean that
ties into the whole elderly population
yeah
people like i want to travel but i don't
want to get on a plane yeah i know i'll
get on a bullet train and go somewhere
completely different yeah it's you know
but let's just be optimistic
let's just be optimistic and let's be
like you know what maybe maybe the old
people will uh change their minds and be
like you know what you know what tourism
tourism good right everybody single wars
started because the old people
pretty much
so so yeah so let's say japan is open
and you are planning a trip to japan and
you've heard us talk about a [ __ ] ton of
things um in like about close to like
100 episodes now so you don't you don't
know where to look because we've we've
been talking about japan's for what
about japan for 100 episodes so you
don't really know even where to start or
maybe we've set a location place in
you're like what or who is that yeah so
we thought we'd it'd be fun to just have
an episode where it's just cl like
collectively what we actually recommend
or don't recommend about japan if you're
gonna plan our trip use this episode as
like a placeholder just to listen to it
and be like oh that sounds interesting
and if the place sucks you can blame us
pretty much i i obviously it depends on
how long you're going for that's the
best yeah yes
we're talking about five days
maybe you can still go out of tokyo yeah
for five days you can very easily just
stay in tokyo and have a great time the
first two times i came to japan i never
left yeah yeah exactly mainly because i
was scared
um and of the old people
i mean you know using the shinkansen's
and stuff is kind of intimidating it is
daunting yeah if no one's ever like
helped you do it yeah no it's it's it's
intimidating because obviously in tokyo
there's a safety net because a lot of
things in tokyo are built with the idea
that there's going to be people from
abroad coming to visit right so a lot of
places a lot of places have you know
english menu still you know you uh it's
way more it's way more friendly and open
whereas if you go outside of tokyo you
want to go eat and you're just like okay
this restaurant probably doesn't have
english on it dark souls
like this this 70 year old shop owner
has probably never seen a foreigner in
her life exactly exactly and it is
daunting you know even even nowadays for
for
uh for us even though if even though
we're well traveled you know sometimes
you know i i can do it but like
sometimes i have to like psych myself up
i'm japanese and i get intimidated yeah
because they look at me and they're like
you're not japanese
oh god what do i do i don't know when it
happened i just stopped giving a [ __ ]
about being awful at japanese like a few
months ago yeah so now now i just talk
and then i get over it yeah i don't i
don't know if i do good but i always get
what i need
yeah so whether or not i'm doing it
right or not i get my i get my tonkatsu
yeah exactly
um but yeah like just pretend okay
you're you've just landed and you're on
a trip with the boys we're gonna show
you around we're gonna show you around
it's your first time to japan life hack
number one okay fly to hannibal don't
[ __ ] fly to narrative yes actually
actually that is that is that's like
that's number one top three locations in
japan that suck ass narrator airport
i mean
it might not be it might not be like
you might not be able to avoid depending
on which airline you fly with like if
you're because i know like a lot of the
major airlines like i think like
emirates and all those will go to narita
yeah nrt you want to go to hnd if you
can
um because you have to get a a train for
one naruto is not in tokyo yeah it's in
chiba right yeah it's like [ __ ]
further away from chiba isn't it yeah
also to get into tokyo will cost you
like 50 bucks yeah yeah oh it depends if
you go on the narrator express which is
like the most famous like bullet train s
thing from narita airport it's like it's
so expensive it's actually like 80 bucks
but there's a skyline as well which you
can get yes but like i didn't know about
that the first time i came to narita
because they don't advertise they don't
totally advertise
or express yeah because it's convenient
yeah it's because like the narita
express um is the big kind of
shinjuku right yeah it goes to shinjuku
all right but uh yeah it's the it's the
big one that's advertised about how to
get into tokyo and like a one-way ticket
there uh using the narita express costs
about i think 80 to 100 bucks yeah [ __ ]
that like 200 bucks yeah
the first few times i went to japan i
didn't i did not know that there were
other choices that you could make
uh so if if you have to fly to narita we
highly recommend the skyline yes which
is cheaper than the cheaper and it stops
it more basically when you get off your
plane at narita are you done go to the
trains and they'll be like a bunch of
ticket things but there'll be one
specific office that says skyliner yeah
you can't miss it uh they speak english
as well so go there yeah and ask them
it's about 40 bucks yeah you pay like
half the price yeah yeah and it's it's
great and it's just as fast it's got a
vending machine it's actually just as
fast which is why i'm just like why is
the narita express twice as expensive
because they can get their money though
yeah yeah but yeah good at hannah
hannah's super easy you're basically in
uh where are you near in canada uh
nearly odaiba yeah yeah yeah yeah took
your time so you're actually one you're
in tokyo two you can you know take the
subway dude the [ __ ] ah you can take
the monorail do the monorail is has a
sick view dude yeah the monorail is
awesome or you can just get a cab if
you're lazy
you can get a cab train or monorail but
the most aesthetic one is definitely the
model a lot of the caps have the uh
english-speaking uh computer thing in it
oh really yeah i've never used it right
i just i just shouted them like go here
but um yeah this uh i've never seen them
maybe i should test it just see how it
goes yeah
yeah so like we said you know first
first step if you can fly to canada we
highly recommend you fly to honda
because you're gonna have such
it's gonna you're gonna have like a way
better experience it's gonna be less
stressful getting just genuinely as well
it's a really nice airport yeah it's a
really nice airport you get better views
and it's also cheaper so that's
basically every reason you could
possibly think of to fly to a certain
airport over another if you have a
choice
it's normally more expensive to go there
but the cost of like the train tickets
and transfers yeah yeah yeah it might
make up for that
yeah exactly so it offsets the cost it's
like it's like gatwick and heathrow yeah
in london gatwick's a joke gatwick's is
basically in brighton what's the [ __ ]
point of the airport it's great for me
it's it's annoying it's [ __ ] it's
literally not in like in london what's
the other airport that you guys are
heathrow no there's one more right oh no
luton now no no no no
then we go to like then we've got like
stansted
[ __ ] like i don't even count those as
like [ __ ] airports okay those getting
to standstill and stuff like that is
more difficult than get it like the
journey like to france yeah right right
yeah it's it's it's ridiculous about
japan we're talking about japan yeah pov
you've just landed in your airport where
where are you gonna stay where would you
recommend staying what's it what's the
best player in tokyo hotel
you've got a lot of options right like a
hotel is literally the same stories
don't do uppers okay but okay well all
right yes you might have to deal with
racist books in your hotel room which
sucks but it's this it's like the same
price as like a capsule hotel
it's a closet because it is a capsule
hotel yeah i mean you get a bed though i
would highly recommend i would highly
recommend airbnbs airbnbs
is my is my best experience in terms of
accommodation staying in tokyo which
might be which might be difficult though
because of the recent like airbnb
even off because i have stayed in
airbnbs since they've got ridden got rid
of a lot of airbnbs and they are still
like 10 times better than most hotels in
tokyo and the reason is because most
hotels in tokyo are they are just
business hotels right there they're
they come with the assumption that
you're just going to stay like the guys
staying there aren't even gonna be gonna
be in the hotel at all yeah unless
you're staying at like a hilton like
everything else is just like yeah
everything else just everything else is
just a closet or a shoebox
there's some decent ones i think i've
stayed in i don't know where are they
yeah reasonably priced i'm sure there is
i think you have to look you do yeah
yeah you do have to look but i feel like
with airbnbs there's just you tokyo is
absolutely saturated with hotels there's
a lot of hotels yeah like because they
nerfed all the airbnb yeah yeah you can
you can definitely find a good hotel if
that's what you want because i get it
sometimes you don't deal with an airbnb
because sometimes you know it's kind of
a weird experience you have to sometimes
really sometimes sometimes you get the
key in a really weird way and sometimes
you're in an apartment building and you
get stared at and stuff and then also
you're like out of the neighbor's
house three times
like you don't really understand how the
the locks work and stuff you're like i
get it a hotel is just like boom card in
there's there's services they can do
your laundry and stuff i get it i just i
just feel like you it's yeah it's it's
it's it's up to you but like to me like
or a connor or a connoisseur
connor just likes to be pampered all the
time
he just wants everything done for him i
want him on a vacay you know a little
vacation a little getaway i i wanna i
wanna worry less about things i wanna
safe in my room yeah but you're also
probably staying at a hilton
that's like that's like a one night
thing if i'm lucky
[Music]
you know i i feel like it's a waste
staying in a luxury hotel for like more
than one just like more than one day
because like you want to do [ __ ] like
you know what i mean like you want to go
outside like just get a hotel with
enough room where you can be comfortable
eating a cup noodle in it if you want
okay
let let me try let me sell you on the
airbnb all right all right guys
okay because with airbnbs you have more
anemones you have like you have a
working [ __ ] microwave or like one of
those like a lot of airbnb's have one of
those mini grills so if you want to like
go to family mart or 7-eleven or lawsons
and buy your buy the famous fried
chicken that's uh that connor and chris
have eaten a lot but you don't want it
cold you can perfectly just grill it in
your airbnb
it's home when you buy it what do you
mean it's warm when you buy it
how how long are you carrying around
this family i don't know i don't i'm not
okay so like
i i will say they're probably the one
country on earth you don't need a
microwave is japan yeah there's
literally one under every corner that
you're allowed to use freely
that is true absolutely that is true
i love this one
i don't know how that was
like guys they have a microwave they
have a microphone don't worry okay okay
but no like normally like i found like
you get more room in the airbnb as well
you like yeah like a lot of the times
the hotel rooms it's just a shoe box
where you don't have room to walk at all
yeah with airbnbs you actually have
walking space sometimes you you have
like a living space and like a bedroom
space which is like which is good uh
another thing is that a lot of airbnbs i
found in japan especially they come with
portable wi-fi right so a lot of the
times you don't want to faff around with
getting data in japan because it's such
it's such a hassle but with so many
airbnbs basically about 90 of airbnbs
i've stayed at the owners are kind
enough to provide you with a portable
wi-fi which not only works as the wi-fi
in the airbnb but works as a portable
wi-fi which you can take with you as
you're traveling around japan although i
will say that i think most if not all
train stations in the tokyo area have
free wi-fi uh
[ __ ] annoying to connect to it though
yeah
but also also every mcdonald's has a
free wi-fi yeah i mean just honestly you
get it from the airport they there's
like a bazillion of these it is
expensive as [ __ ] though data is
expensive especially if
you're going to need it though honestly
yeah yeah you are going you are apps
google maps is literally your best
friend on there yeah i still use it with
the amount of walking you're going to do
yeah everyone's like if you have like an
international plan for data or something
i i highly recommend that because
buying data here which is why i
recommend airbnbs if they give you
portable wi-fi buying data here as a
tourist is really really [ __ ]
expensive it's like 70 dollars for like
there's two weeks ago there's vending
machines
vending machines at the airport that do
sim cards
really do
data only sim cards yeah they are quite
pricey but you know it will do what you
need to do because i mean google changes
you get a vending machine experience
right off the bat right yeah well oh my
god i've never bought a similar vending
machine oh my god a vending machine that
actually works yeah yeah um there's also
you can just like type in portable wi-fi
whatever airport you're going to
there'll be ones you can get as well
yeah well one piece of advice for me
that i want to tell people is get a
seeker
oh yeah oh yeah because that's going to
be your best friend as well this is this
is a suica card okay this is the
equivalent to an oyster card although i
don't believe we use it
like metrocards um it's really easy uh
because
you can get one at basically any machine
on the metro or anything like that here
like 500 yen yeah it's like it's like
500 yen and you can load it up
immediately um every machine has an
english option and multiple other
languages as well so you don't need to
worry about learning japanese to buy a
car it's super easy and the same
bullet trains yeah also you can pay with
it if you don't want to deal with cash
load up a [ __ ] ton of money every single
fast food chain and every single conbini
will accept it everywhere mostly vending
machines as well yeah
machines
which is which is very very useful
because if you don't
if you don't remember this then you're
going to be needing to bring cash do not
expect to be able to pay by card
anywhere just just
some places do accept it but don't
expect to come into a place even if it
looks like a you know a big
establishment that should have a card
machine a lot of places don't accept
cards or even credit cards to be fair it
is getting better
like a lot more places now especially
like since when i first moved i
remembered like half the places i went
to didn't accept card at all but like i
feel nowadays like most places in
central tokyo except card but yeah also
you know it's the suka is good because
again you can use it not just at a
restaurant but literally anywhere yeah
um so super handy yeah but also just
carry cash with you always yeah because
you're going to need it for something in
japan yeah um even if you don't know
what it is immediately there's always
going to be one little thing where this
place doesn't accept anything but cash
or machine doesn't accept anything but
cash you're going to need it so don't
don't assume that uh we're like in
japan's like every other you know first
world country where uh we have uh
like a mom and pop like shop right yeah
really like the old like restaurants and
stuff like that they'll usually just be
like nope cash only yeah yeah